Alright guys, so here is another example of the market maker buy model. As you can see, we took out the external liquidity right here. So now we have this fair value gap in the premium. So that is going to be our drawn liquidity. So let's go to the five minute remember from one hour we go to five minute right. Now we have taken out our objective. So let's identify consolidation phases. So right here we have one consolidation. And that is going to be our original consolidation right here. Right? Let's move this up like that.
So we have control decision here and consolidation here.
These two lines are fairly gap.
So that is gonna be our drawn liquidity.
What do we have after taking out the objective,
which is external liquidity?
We have a market structure shift here.
Now, if you don't know, if you're confused
as to why is this a market structure shift,
go and watch my video on YouTube,
which says, how to identify high probability
market structure shifts, right?
Price didn't take out this high,
but it did a break of structure instead of market structure
shift.
Now once you have a break double break of structure
after price takes out a key level,
that is a valid market structure shift,
if that makes sense.
Just watch that video on YouTube.
So we have this auto block here,
consecutive perish candles going long just right here.
We put our shop right below this auto block
and we target this level, which is a drawn liquidity, right?
The consolidation phase tells us
that we are in a market maker buy model.
It gives us confidence.
So playing this through, you can see that the take profit level was instantly hit.
And we took out this range, this consolidation high as well,
giving us 2.29RR.
So let's move on to the next example.